after another week of delay and the
Cavanaugh conformation saga the FBI
supplemental report is in and it appears
the Democrats have lost another one what
we know for sure is the FBI report did
not corroborate any of the allegations
against judge Cavanaugh even the
undecided hamlet figure Jeff Flake said
the report doesn't contain any new
corroboration while Susan Collins called
it very thorough now let me say again
the report all 46 pages of it apparently
produced zero corroborating evidence to
back up the accusations of Cavanaugh's
accusers but as we've come to expect
straightforward factual revelations have
zero influence on Democrats going wild
across America for instance at the
University of Vermont
they held a canceled class cancel
Cavanaugh Ally how clever in Brooklyn
New York and Bel Air Maryland there were
similar calls to kill Cavanaugh's
nomination and here in Washington DC the
hate machine was ramped up to full
throttle but it's an anger most
effective when it becomes a chant
[Music]
oh who needs chants that rhyme anyway
and what would aunty Cavanaugh
pro-abortion protests be without a few
Hollywood heavyweights
well model Emily Rachel ski showed some
outrage and some midriff and comedian
Amy Schumer was as usual politically
understated a vote for Cavanaugh is a
vote saying women don't matter let's
stay together let's fight let's keep
showing up well the good thing is that
when she was arrested she actually
didn't have to put on prison garb she
was already wearing it and all over the
Capitol there were roving survivors
accosting senators undecided about
Cavanaugh's nomination so they attempted
at one point this afternoon you love
this to pull a flake and bully senators
like Joe Manchin of West Virginia into
casting a no vote
[Music]
I love that step back
I love wonder why they always saying
look at me we see you believe me we're
averting our gaze the Democrats brazen
intimidation and harassment tactics I
don't know I think they're a total
turnoff Americans just don't like this
stuff most people just want things to
calm down
well Rasmussen daily tracking poll has
the president's approval today at 50%
not bad a new IBD poll finds it at 40% a
4-point gain from last month and even
better that same poll shows that the
supercharged enthusiasm is on the
Republican side the Democrats advantage
tanked from 11 points last month to just
2 points this month
still the Democrats will not give up the
most notable part of this report is
what's not in it as we noted by the
White House the FBI did not interview
Brett Kavanaugh nor did the FBI
interview dr. Blasi Ford given how
limited this these documents were and
how limited the scope of this
investigation was we are reiterating our
call that the documents with proper
redaction be made public
why shouldn't all of America see the
facts okay I think Feinstein should have
worn a white scarf for surrender don't
you think that would have been more
appropriate well Americans now have the
facts Democrats wanted a witch hunt and
it fizzled over a lack of evidence the
facts Americans will now focus on I
think are the ones the left fear the
most the economic record of Donald J
Trump jobless claims have dropped to a
49 year low we now have four point two
percent GDP growth with projections now
to match or exceed that in the upcoming
quarter manufacturing job number
President Obama
said they were never coming back are
growing at the fastest rate in 23 years
Trump's Republican Party is actually
offering something called results also
on foreign policy trade the agenda that
people voted for meanwhile the Democrats
offer Americans only this isn't over yet
oh there you go well the door has closed
but Democrats are still howling or
screeching if you just heard that again
none of this is a governing agenda it's
just more chaos harassment
anger and agitation and you really want
to vote for more of that in November and
that's the angle